Robert Baratheon's victory at the
Trident was a turning point in the war
for the Iron Throne while it was clear
the gods were smiling on the rebel
forces Aerys Targaryen still held the
red key at King's Landing as Robert was
wounded and unable to ride it was up to
Eddard Stark to make further capital and
force the Mad King to give up the throne
Lord Stark reached the city gates to
find that Tywin Lannister Lord of
Casterly Rock had already sacked the
city in Robert's name House Lannister
had remained neutral up to this point
ignoring requests for help from both the
crown and the rebels now that Roberts
eventual victory was assured
it seemed Lord Tywin had finally chosen
the side Lord Eddard was horrified by
what he saw when he entered the city
homes looted and burned women raped
scores of innocent citizens killed
disgusted he led his force up the sanyas
hill to the red keep upon entering the
throne room he found King Aerys lying in
a pool of blood dead by the hand of his
own sworn Kingsguard Jaime Lannister who
sat brazenly upon the throne demanding
to know the whereabouts of Queen rhaella
Lord Eddard was informed the Queen and
her son Viserys had been spirited away
to Dragonstone before the Lannisters
arrived but other members of the royal
family were not as fortunate Elia
Martell of Dorne who was the wife of
Prince Rhaegar had been raped and
murdered by Sirk rig or Clegane on Lord
Tywin's orders so Grigor and his man had
also butchered Rhaegar's young children
when Robert was well enough to reach the
capital Lord Eddard demanded the
Lannisters answer for their heinous
crimes Robert refused and sent him south
to relieve the Baratheon stronghold of
storm's end which was still under siege
by forces loyal to the crown
whatever words passed between the two
old friends and only to them but Lord
Eddard is said to have left King's
Landing in hangar later when Robert was
crowned he appointed Jon Arryn as hand
of the king
Lord Erin's first order of business was
to broker a truce with the Martel's of
Dorne who were outraged by the brutal
murder of princess Elia and her children
following the death of Lyanna stark who
had been betrothed to Robert houses
Baratheon and Lannister were joined in
marriage when the new king took Tywin
Lannister's eldest daughter Cersei as
his queen as for Eddard Stark he
returned to his stronghold of Winterfell
forever haunted by his sister's death
and the shameful way that Robert had
secured his throne